today there is a small step towards
trying to ease the coronavirus
restrictions across nevada
things slowly going back to normal yeah
and starting this morning business
capacity limits will be raised to 35
percent
at restaurants bars gyms and amusement
parks it's great news hector mejia live
inside a local donut shop
with reaction to the latest changes hey
hector happy monday
hey there good morning happy monday to
everyone and this is a
welcoming reopening sign for so many
business owners who tell us
it'll really help them out with their
sales here at wikidona
donuts it means that they can allow
about four or five additional customers
here
joining us live we have chef robert
teddy here not only to talk to us about
the delicious donuts here but also you
know you guys had some challenges
with the 25 capacity uh before and now
you guys are getting a small
bump right well that's right we're
getting a small pump which
really helps us and it helps
the customers feel more comfortable
to kind of jam in a little bit
i want to get out of the way so you guys
can see the delicious donuts here and
you guys have been busy throughout the
morning
you open the drive-through at 5 30 and
you're already getting
sales in this early oh absolutely
it starts at 5 30 and
doesn't stop so tell us does it feel
like a
huge sigh of relief with the uh 10 bump
some say it's not a lot others say you
know anything helps
we will take anything and that's right
and so you know that's
that's how it is we're always
hoping that the governor will continue
to expand of course and you know it's
also interesting to highlight that we're
just
a month away on march 15th that's when
the capacity is set to
increase again capped at 50 percent for
most
for almost all businesses and activities
here across the state of course as long
as the
numbers for kobe cases keep dropping but
for you guys it was challenging
when you guys had the restrictions the
earlier restrictions
oh absolutely you know kevin's we have a
drive through that's helped a lot you
were telling it that
really helped a lot in the beginning in
august when we opened
the inside was shut and so we couldn't
have
survived without our director yeah
thank you very much chef we'll be back
in a few minutes to talk a little bit
more about the
restrictions and you know as customers
show up to make those orders for now
reporting live hector mckia
eight news now back to you guys hector
it has been so hard for all sorts of
businesses restaurants to try and
survive so 35 percent
uh certainly helps and by the way a
doughnut drive through through
might be the most dangerous thing i've
ever heard of in my life so it sounds
tasty
hector thank you sir it is now 606